this is a production of cornell
university
i want to thank the committee and allen
for this opportunity to
give an update on some of the things
that
we have going on with compatibility uh
for fungicides and insecticide seed
treatments with rhizobia and biocontrol
agents i think this is a really
interesting topic
and a lot of times when i'm asked to
give a presentation
uh these type of talks
to groups like this are really
interesting to me because it's
a topic that's a little bit different
than i'm normally used to talking to
which is
more about how our products work and
efficacy and things like that but
when i give one of these talks i do
quite a bit of research and i tend to
learn a lot about
uh this this new topic and it was in
this case too that i really
felt like i was able to learn some
things so i hope that
through this time that we spend here in
the next few minutes i can
give you some of that information that i
learned and that you'll find it
interesting
so rhizobia are
important in legume crops for increased
nodulation
and nitrogen management their use
decreases the need for synthetic
fertilizers
and helps growers far more sustainably
rhizobia products are often
seed applied and the advances in seed
applied bio control agents have
also occurred in recent years and many
new products are being brought to the
market and are often seed applied as
well
fungicide insecticide seed treatments
are still very valuable to growers and
the compatibility of these different
products are very important
to ensure that growers are getting the
expected benefit of all the products
applied
rhizobia and bio control compatibility
begins with the design of the fungicide
or insecticide formulation
and includes the active ingredient as
well as the choice of inert ingredients
the compatibility is evaluated at
several stages
which i'll go through through the
development products
process and is often checked by rhizobia
product companies as well before
commercialization
and also responsible bio-controlled
product companies are also testing for
compatibility of their products
when it makes sense and they believe
that their product is going to be
applied as a seed treatment
and by working together the industries
really trying hard
to make sure that these products are
working together in effect can be used
effectively
to uh the best maximize the yield and
farm
sustainability so that's uh in a summary
really what i've been trying i want to
share with you today and i'm going to go
into a lot more
detail now about about these so
as you know rhizobium is a genus of soil
bacteria
and the fact that it's bacteria means
that this is a living organism that's
being applied to the seed and that
brings
certain considerations that we need to
think about
an important feature of these rhizobium
is that they're very specific
to the the legume
or that they're being applied to so some
of them
have very are only specific to of a very
small
amount of the crops for example
some of them are only only
nodulate on alfalfa species
whereas other rhizobium can be very
broad broad spectrum across a number of
of crops
for for us there's a rhizobium legume
sorum is nodulates on pea crops
and brady japonicum nodulates in
soybeans
this is important because we're not just
talking about one specific
uh bacterial organism that
is applied across all crops that we need
to worry about
but there's many different
rhizobia species that we have to think
about and test for when we're talking
about compatibility with
seed treatments that are also going on
that same space on the seed
and i just have a picture here of you
can see the nodulation on the roots
so what we're talking about is the uh
these rhizobia that are applied to the
seed and then
or in furrow in some cases and then
cause these nodulations and what this is
really doing is this uh
rhizobia bacteria is colonizing the
plant cells
within root nodules and they're they
convert atmospheric nitrogen into
ammonia causing the enzyme
nitrogenase and then provide organic
nitrogenous compounds such as glutamine
or urides to the plant so it's really
helping the plant
the plant in turn is providing the
bacteria with organic compounds
made by photosynthesis and this is a
mutually beneficial relationship
and it is true of rhizobia which is
example
which of which the genus rhizobium is a
typical
so this mutually beneficial relationship
is something that we really want to make
sure we're protecting and
make sure that we're taking advantage of
especially when we're trying to reduce
fertilizer
use synthetic fertilizer use as much as
possible
we want to try to increase our soil
health
so rhizobium can be formulated with
other micro microorganisms
as well to improve or add additional
benefits
and i i've just taken a snip here from
a nova zyme's document and you can see
that there's a rhizobian legion of sorum
but there's also penicillium on here as
well
and these uh rhizobium products can
actually take different
carriers or different forms you can have
peat
you can have granulars or you could have
liquid inoculants
so all of these need to be considered as
well
so that's a little bit about the
rhizobium
but what about a seed treatment and
although it sometimes might seem like it
uh
you know you just had a nice talk from
peter marks and
you can make these seeds look really
nice and it might seem like it's about
the colors and the shiny
shiny appearance it's it's more about
the how what what the products are doing
to protect them against
insects nematodes and diseases which are
mainly
mainly fungi and these have been very uh
useful to growers and they're getting a
lot of benefit out of them you can see
here
if you have an untreated seeds and you
have planted
in the presence of pythium sometimes
you'll
basically get no plants but a treated
seed can protect you from
pythium and this can be demonstrated in
little rhizotrons like this where we've
inoculated the soil
we can also do petri plate studies you
can see here
an untreated petri plate with
rhizoctonia in the center and the
rhizoctonia mycelium growing out across
the seeds
whereas the treated seeds are protected
from the rhizoctonia
and this is the benefit that these seed
treatments are
are giving to growers so we want to be
able to
combine both of these technologies
together and be able to use them
efficiently we want them both to perform
well when we're talking about the
pesticide formulation
there is the pesticide active ingredient
that is the main
component that we're talking about
that's the thing that's going to be
controlling the pest there's carriers
uh water or organic solvents that are
also in those formulations
these are all the inner of the inert or
other ingredients and we're when we're
talking about compatibility with
something like a
rhizobium or bacteria we really need to
consider
all of these inert ingredients as well
as the
active ingredient other things that can
be in there are surfactants
or adjuvants stabilizers you can have
dyes or colorants
and safeners as well as antifreezes to
keep it from freezing
in cold temperatures another thing that
is often or
almost always put into a
pesticide formulation or a seed
treatment formulation
are synthetic biocides so the synthetic
biocides are placed in there so we don't
get bacterial contamination growing in
the
in the jug if you've ever opened a jug
and it smells really bad
you know you have some bacterial
contamination
and the biocides weren't doing their job
so
these are all uh components of a
seed treatment formulation and you can
see that some of these are going to
cause some problems
when you're trying to be compatible with
an organic or a
with an organism that's a living organic
solvents uh biopest
biocides could be could be an issue
and so we need to uh take care of that
and how
how are we gonna do that um
i just wanna say you know syngentis has
a long history of developing these
things we've been
doing this for over 40 years and we
spend a lot of money and time
investing in our formulations nearly 4
million dollars a day and we don't want
to
have a product that is going to
come to the market and not be successful
or not be able to be used
because of its incompatibility with
with the rhizobium or another bio
control product that our growers
really want to apply to help us with
this we do have dedicated seed care
specialists around the country that
listen to grow listen to growers and try
to understand how our products are
working
and there also can be resources for you
if you're having an issue with one of
our products or have questions about
them you can always
contact one of them we have
a facility in minnesota which is a seed
care institute where we do a lot of
training
but this is also where we do application
testing
like peter was talking about and we have
uh inoculum testing program as well as
our seed safety testing program
so what does syngenta do to keep our
products compatible with inoculants uh
actually in the formulation development
of a new
seed treatment we do do tests for
compatibility
and these tests are might primarily
to put the product on the seed after
well we applied treat the seed and then
we put the inoculum on top
and then we'll see how long those uh
inoculum last on the seed or how long it
survives on the seed
and we have a certain threshold that we
want to maintain
for the number of a bacterial
bacteria that are still alive on the
seed after a certain amount of time
and so we do test that in the
development process
we only test a few of those to make sure
that this products
not not a significant issue and if it
passes that test
then we'll continue with the development
of that formulation and we feel that it
will be successful
we'll go ahead and freeze that
formulation and
commercialize it however before
after kind of after the the products
frozen or we've got a good
idea of what that product is going to be
we've gone through some tests
we will offer our products for testing
to other
inoculant manufacturers for testing
prior to commercialization and if we
come back and there's some big issues
we will uh withhold that
product from the marketplace currently
the only company that's really been
taking us
up on this offer is novazymes so i'm
going to be sharing some
information from novazymes but we do
they do test the compatibility of all
our new formulations and
treatments with with their inoculant
products and
it's something that syngenta doesn't
really have the expertise to do in-house
so we have
the inoculant companies are really good
at testing those things
and we have them them do that and when
they give us back the information
and then they publish it in a guide so
you can download
this guide you know i did last week from
from novazymes and it's a compatibility
guide and it gives you
by crop all of the different products
that they have i've just taken a snip
of one of them which is tag team pete
and then it lists all of the
products that have been
tested by syngenta or i'm
tested by novazones i'm sorry and you
can see there's a
pretty big list of those products here
and i just want to highlight a few
this one is a apron max rfc the rfc
actually stood for rhizobium friendly
constant concentrate we did make some
modifications to the formulation
to help it be more uh friendly to
to rhizobium actually than the original
aprimax rta formulation and you can see
that it did
seem to improve the planting window and
this planting window is actually
the maximum amount of time that can
elapse between the date the seed was
treated with the bio
bioenhancer or rhizobium
and when it can be planted within
expectation
that the rhizobium will remain viable
and generally this is uh i've seen these
really the the maxim here is 48 hours on
all of these
tests that they do however we know from
some of our internal testing that they
do last on the scene
they can last one seed longer but
generally the the greatest limit here is
48 hours
there are some products older products
sometimes or other formulations that
you'll see are not recommended at all
for whatever reason they were not
compatible with the
inoculum product and so those are ones
that you really need to
to look at and watch out for and maybe
choose a different inoculant that was
more compatible with the product that
you want to apply
or potentially choose a different c
treatment
product like i said we do do
testing you know we offer our products
for testing so these are products that
aren't on the list or on on the guide
yet so these are new
syngenta products that have been
recently commercialized and we've done
testing with those and you can see that
they're also 48 hours
for the simultaneous sequential and tank
mixed
timings application timings and
if you don't see one of the products on
the
application guide from the inoculant
company the
manufacturer of the seed treatment may
have this information
with them and we do put this information
in our technical bulletins and technical
presentations so it
it is available because we know that
those guides aren't updated all the time
so how do we avoid problems with the
seed treatment and inoculants
we want to avoid using products with
negative effects of course
when the formulation process we're
trying to use the
products that would be trying to avoid
the ones that are really
negative and there's always the acute
toxicity
the exposure dose and the length of the
exposure and if you see this uh
lady girl sitting here this is a
famous painting from the from 1800s
and there's a really nice green
wallpaper in the background
and she's lucky that she has the window
open here because
this green wallpaper in the victorian
areas was
color was due to arsenic and they used
arsenic to make that green color in the
wallpaper and they had a lot of problems
with people actually getting sick
when in the winter was closed up and
they would be in here and
actually get sick from the arsenic in
the in the wallpaper that was coming out
so if she had she's lucky she had the
window open if she'd been outside or
away from that
she could have avoided it or taken down
the wallpaper
eliminated that then you're able to
not be exposed to that toxic
toxicity so in
similarly for to test compatibility
we have different ways we can apply the
the
inoculum or the the bio control agent
you can do a simultaneous application
a sequential application or a tank mix
application
tank mix application is kind of like
being right in the room with with the
product
this is uh a diagram that i got from a
bsf
document from canada and it shows very
nicely what a sequential application is
where the seed treatment must be applied
and allowed to dry
before the inoculant is applied the
simultaneous
application the seed treatment can be
applied
at the same time as the inoculant but
separate applicators must be used
and then the tank mix application
basically the inoculant is mixed
directly with the
diluted seed treatment and applied as
one solution
however they do recommend that the
maximum
hours of the slurry that's mixed up in
it you have to be applied within six
hours
and some other uh people recommend
within four hours
there is also a best practices guide so
novazyme says produced a bio egg best
practices
guide for using inoculants and it has a
lot of really good information around
how to keep these organisms
working and compatibility with seed
treatments
for living organisms you know that they
depend
on us as applicators to
exerg exercise good storage practices
before and after the application
you want to make sure that there's cool
temperatures that favor
the survival of the bacteria found in
the inoculants
store the products and seed to which the
products have been applied in a cool dry
place
and refer to the conditions
on the product and seed labels for
specific recommendations
on how to best keep those organisms
happy
the other thing is you can have a
dedicated tank
and for the inoculum and a pumping
system this will allow for easy
management of the inocument or
biological products
and while the standard seed treatments
are generally stable
if left in a mixed tank for a few days
before consumed it's not true for
inoculants
a dedicated tank would allow you to open
and mix
only what you need for immediate use and
keeping your
inoculant source as fresh and as viable
as possible
and even with the dedicated tank need to
apply all
of the product within 24 hours after
opening
and if you don't have a dedicated tank
you can
choose to mix the inoculants with the
treatment but if this
is done that like i said you need to be
using all of that slurry with up within
four to six hours
and another important thing is to clean
out your equipment
and make sure that you have good
sanitation throughout so that the
sea treatment and the and the inoculant
that you use in the next
next batch are also compatible or make
sure things are clean
another thing that a lot of people don't
really think about is the water
so you may be treating with a city water
and as we know they treat city water
with
with chlorine to help kill microbes in
the water so
this is not going to be compatible with
your inoculum
and so if you're treating with the city
water which has chlorine added
you may want to install a water filter
which is designed to remove the
chlorine or use a spare tank where you
can
hold the water for 24 hours and allow
the chlorine to dissipate before you
use it in your slurry also many treaters
use
soybean oil to help or other oils to
help
with the treatment process and generally
this has been shown not to be an issue
and doesn't seem to have any effect or
harm on the
on the bacteria and it also may even
improve the
quality a little bit because it dries a
little bit slower than just
straight water it's also other
important to check all of the other
things that you're adding to the
the mixture the slurry in in addition to
the seed treatment part you can add
other polymers or colors or maybe
another product
uh from somewhere and you want to make
sure you check all of those when you're
applying it with a with an inoculant
so important to think about all of the
things that are going into your slurry
i've talked a lot about the inoculants i
talked about the
seed treatments and now another growing
area is really a biological
so a lot of these biologicals could be
living organisms as well what are really
growers looking for
for a biological we're trying to unlock
soil-bound nutrients we're trying
to enhance access to those nutrients fix
atmospheric nitrogen stimulate
development or protect
against pathogens so
and some of these can be live organisms
or
plant extracts small peptides
all kinds of things that you want to
make sure
those are the integrity of those is
maintained when you're mixing them
for bio control usually these can be it
could be viruses
bacterial fungal pathogens pheromones or
botanicals or other substances
in biostimulants you could have
microbial products
nitrogen fixing bacteria algal extracts
humic acids amino acids peptides enzymes
vitamins
all kinds of things nutrients are
usually
micro or macro nutrients that generally
are not
considered incompatible with seed
treatments
in a living sense but could be
incompatible
from a physical chemistry type of sense
so if the biological or the organism is
actually a living organism
the same kind of rules would apply as
we've talked about for the rhizobium
bacteria
you want to make sure that those are
happy and those conditions for that
organism
are satisfied and want to test and make
sure that those
bacteria are still alive on the on the
seed after
after application that it's compatible
and the testing for this compatibility
is done by a lot of the biological
companies that are bringing these new
products to the market
we're often approached by companies that
ask for product to test
when they're starting out trying to
determine if they can
apply a product to the seed and if that
would be a mechanism
of delivery for their product or
potentially they would have to go in
furrow
and do a application that way instead of
applying it with the seed treatment
they're also trying to figure out
whether they can do the tank mix or it
would be built
it could be built into a formulation a c
treatment formulation
or if it's better doing a sequential
application something like that
and so this there's a lot of work that's
been done in this
this area but if you're not sure about
the products you're using
or if they've been tested it's always
good to ask
you know ask the manufacturer what what
the compatibility is
and what kind of testing's been done we
do syngenta
doesn't do a lot of compatibility
testing
of all the products the biological
products on the market unless we have an
agreement
with that company that we're interested
in they're biological
or they've asked us to test it or
have to supply some product for them to
test but there is
testing going on
so i did mention uh you know just
a lot about the biologicals that were
thinking about
and how they're compatible trying to
keep them alive
but there's also physical compatibility
and some of these other products that i
mentioned
uh humic acids the
they're not they're not living but
they're products that are being applied
on the seed as biological and
it's important to look at the
compatibility of those if you're going
to apply those at the same time or put
them into your slurry
and one of the best ways to do that is
to do a jar test
and you can learn a lot from a jar test
that'll save you a lot of trouble
cleaning out lines and tanks and
cleaning up the mess later
we do tests with our products with
biologicals that we are thinking about
or we know that may be
put into a into a tank mix
and one of the things we're looking for
is the incompatibility just physical
incompatibility
uh change in viscosity change in
appearance or
physical behavior or separation like you
can see here in this
this jar and that's something you want
to try
to avoid sometimes there's a little bit
of separation but if it's recirculated
easily
then we usually say that that would be
acceptable
and there's also compatibilities where
we increase the temperature
decrease the temperature make sure that
in a range of temperatures it's okay
so there's a lot of tests that are done
with just physical compatibility
also it's very important to clean the
equipment when changing formulation
types
just a good cleanliness really helps out
with
seed treating and making sure that
everything is is
compatible and flowing easily and
another
one way to clean out easily is using a
simple green something like that
so i did go through quickly quite a lot
of
information and i just wanted to
talk a little bit about some of the
sources of the information i have
there's the bio
nova zones bio ag c treatment
compatibility guide
this i did take some information from
the 2013 one but there is another one
that
was updated more recently and there's a
best practices guide that's available
online
from this january there was some
information you can find
from compatibility of different
inoculants from
from bsf in canada there's a
syngenta technical bulletins or
technical bulletins from your company
or other c treatment companies about
the inoculum compatibility or biological
compatibilities
and then there's different papers that
you can read about online
quite a lot of journal articles and
other information that you can you can
go to to
really dig into some of this as well so
if
with that if if there's any time left
i'd like to
you know get take some questions
david thank you very much for the for
the talk yes just
a a question or so it's again packing a
lot of information in a short amount of
time
and again yes also again the cca credits
there's your information to go ahead and
get those cca credits
so a question for david on compatibility
of the seed treatment
chemical seed treatments with the
rhizobia or the bio controls
okay and i don't see anything in the
chat right now okay
david again thank you very much thank
you very much for this great
presentation
you're welcome
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu